la centrale électrique de laurent sq ne
fournit plus d'électricité alors on sq
capitale régionale à 20 km de là
contrôlée par les séparatistes depuis
2014 à l'époque les combats ont fait
rage ici pour le contrôle de cette
infrastructure stratégique
l'armée ukrainienne a fini par triompher
mais les séquelles sont encore là
[Musique]
d'abord facebook
dans cette chasse a fini à dix
pour son combustible du charbon
anthracite l'usiné dépendante de la
russie car les réserves d'ukrainiens
sont en territoire séparatiste ici les
coupeurs de livraison sont courantes
comme entre novembre dernier et janvier
de cette année lusine tout comme les
soldats stationnés à proximité vivent
dans la crainte permanente d'une attaque
ministre kosovar matinale joizil
pourquoi je n'aborde pas trace pour
l'instant si le trône est riche et
soeurs qui se fait lui demandant son
ex ingénieur à l' usine rallye n'a
kalinin a co dirige une ong qui organise
des ateliers culturels pour adultes et
enfants
un exutoire pour soulager langue ouest
une attaque russe la ruda venir nous il
ne possède à son parc baptisé zabra
tessiture en scooter
électrique h astia les patriotes de
l'ukraine comme malina sont minoritaires
toute ville annonce sa propre chaîne
target of duke et au titre si on astique
smartos motel6 trafic et les canards
nash cattori vidyo précises comme la
parade ce que galina partage avec ses
voisins c'est la peur de voir revenir
les combats
mais ceux qui suivent la télévision
russe blâmerait sans doute contrairement
elle l'ukraine